j'avais un copain qui dans le petit
milieu journalistique où j'étais allé
fait naître une rumeur
ouais le fait d'être irradiés irradiait
aussi le vizir d'accortes à dire que
donner une force incroyable des mesures
et voilà mais en fait poussé plus dans
le nez et donc oui
et figurez-vous qu'il a fait naître
cette rumeur et j'ai eu trois
sollicitation directe de consoeurs
journalistique voulant tester mon physio
pu tester votre is your way home ou dix
ans mais dis donc on n'a jamais connu ça
est ce que ça joue 8 ha oui vous venez
et donc elles ont voulu tester vous
allez en fait destinée pas fait parce
que j'étais avec quelqu'un et puis avec
qui à l'époque 4,1 à l'époque
sandrine sandrine away il ya des
sandrine yahvé isabelle avant non non
nathalie nathalie wood et pour moi c'est
énorme
3 sollicitations pour moi c'est énorme
et alors aidant vous n'avez rien fait
non mais en fait alors je sais pas si
c'est l'effet du plutonium mais ça va
merci